hey everybody welcome back to koala zoo
and today it is time to work on a well a
habitat at last for me this is my first
ever habitat in equality zoo so working
for the chimpanzees for context as
always we have lady Mike and Rudy out
here how are you guys doing it's been a
hectic week I've started doing a
full-time internship I'm like
representing the Netherlands on Twitter
this week and in the meantime I'm trying
to do my best to scramble a little
episode for koala soo here as well but
yeah shall we yeah yeah it's the idea
that I went into this for is actually
something that when I send some work in
progress pictures Rudy you recognize
this straightaway there's this there's
this school in Bali which has a really
cool bamboo architecture with different
floors all supported by a bamboo
structure which I thought was a really
really cool idea so I wanted to try
something very similar just with a
different sort of roof shape and
composition to it but other than that
just a complete ripoff and that's
basically what this is turning into it's
a sort of viewing platform for both the
chimpanzee habitats well the futures
impotency habitat as well as this sort
of River area that mike has been
building on the other side in the mean
time which looks absolutely beautiful so
yeah that's basically what this is all
about it's also a little bit of a weenie
I would say I'm not saying yes to get it
out here but it just it just magically
works out to that this is sort of a
point where a lot of the little pathways
that Mike
it's been building through this area
converge sort of their viewpoints so the
plan is that you'll see this loom in the
distance above the river that flows
through the park from different
perspectives as well as when you're
walking into this area so it's hopefully
gonna be a bit of an attention-grabber
in that sense as well you want your
architecture to loom I'm curious you say
future habitat does that mean you're
going to make a more episodes project
out of it or are you going to finish it
before you upload this video at the end
of this video I'm gonna have to be
honest it's gonna be a bit unfinished
although technically the chimpanzees
would be able to enter the habitats I
did get you know the basic walls in and
climbing pieces and everything that they
need it's just not fully themed yet but
then I tried running the game because
I've been building all of this on past
mode which is more or less fine but when
I tried running the game to actually let
the chimpanzees in the game went down to
as low as 1 FPS with peaks in getting
into the 8 FPS but I know what that is
that is probably just a game trying to
find the pathway and calculated and that
can take a while but I don't know how
long you were waiting I mean I was
waiting for a few minutes but maybe at
most frame rates it just wasn't enough
I mean I needed to wait like 20 minutes
it helped that you just saved the game
close to game and I restarted not if it
should yeah if they didn't calculate it
at least once it's kind of tedious shot
that so because the first time they ever
need to find that and the more
complicated it is and the more different
pathways you have the longer it takes
okay afterwards it's fine because
afterwards it only as far as my
experience goes afterwards it's only the
new additions you know as soon as to
change something
game only recalculates these areas so
the other tough is fine yeah yeah it
makes sense the first time is terrible
so I always say I recommend to hit play
every now and then but honestly I also
forget so I always always save the game
before I before I let any animal try to
get that traversable area especially you
need the first time yeah it can be a
pain yeah definitely yeah I'm sorry to
be very concerned about my computer as
well might get like an overheating
graphics card at some point so I'm
probably just gonna because I'm running
out of options because my computer is
starting to handle this bike very poorly
so I should probably do like a Windows
reset or just you know completely reboot
the system at some points just to try
and fix it up because it's it's barely
holding it together back in the days
when we did qawalli Beach I had the same
issue
it was terrible yeah but it was a lot of
fun having a new computer being able to
run qawalli I mean back in the day sylph
and I had kind of the the best computers
possible are not possible but at least
the best of the ones there playing it
and then now these computers like
starting to have some issues yeah three
four years ago it's been a while I mean
it's not powerful yeah yes your phone
that your you have in your pockets more
powerful than SILS computer right now I
don't know if I would go quite that far
it is still an NVIDIA GTX 970 and an i7
CPU so you know it's it's not quite top
of the line you know that's true try to
restarted before you
before you checked out the zoo again or
have you been running the game the whole
day without stopping no you have been oh
no a few days I've actually yeah the
thing is actually this episode has been
recorded in very unusual sort of way for
me usually I like to get into the groove
and just you know keep going but due to
just time constraint reasons I've
recorded this episode like 1 or 2 hours
a day for a bunch of days in a row so if
definitely like restarted and closed the
game every time but yet it's a curious
case this park is also just getting huge
the amount of foliage and the amount of
pieces in here is just can you guys
imagine before sylph got this park and
we recorded Mike his episode he was like
oh the next day I'll see why I did do a
few things more so I'm gonna send you
new foul and I was like oh my god oh you
mean you made no oh oh yeah don't talk
about that no yeah no it's actually
really cool quickly is I took Rudy's
area where he had built that kind of
underground space so that we could get
trucks and stuff into like some macho
Island and the backstage area I just
cleaned that up oh yeah of course she
did but this time it was not because
there is nothing to change it was
basically I just put a starting point
there and said hey guys roll with it
because I was lazy I didn't even touch
the tunnel like I saw there is something
now but solo was an archer in there I
gotta say I gotta say if I were frontier
I would love to see them just adding one
Archer now to the game just randomly in
the next
eight you know just for us that would be
so amazing
why do people keep using an archer like
you can just grab a group of people and
see the size I don't have an archer than
to grab a group of people is also our
next to it and then I don't placed him I
just for the size I just moved them and
to see if something is high enough but
have you seen how cute that Archer is
he's adorable
I think I like that these kind of inside
jokes carry along into the next planet
game you know five planet games later
and the community is so extremely niche
that nobody can ever get into it anymore
I see I see plan the sky that is coming
and then people still use the arch of
scale that's gonna be interesting so
interesting it's something different I
will yeah no I actually this this
time-lapse is is has lots of cuts in it
so it's kind of going all over the place
but at this point I sort of finished the
building I just added some minor touches
here and there but this is where we
start work on the actual habitat and the
surrounding here nice mostly just to
frame the building as well because you
know it's YouTube's YouTube and I need
to make that bread so you got to get a
catchy thumb but also I need to you know
locate this building inside a believable
area as opposed to chocolate mountain
which is currently located as chocolate
I'm pretty sure this map kind of looks
like a Mario 60 mi Rio kart 64 at this
point it does it looks a little Mario 64
to the
[Laughter]
we should ask an Indonesian what
chocolate Mountain is okay like a name
how you say that that's a really good
idea that's how the most stupid ideas
ever for product start and then actually
it reminds me of I don't know if you
guys are into Halo or something
you know is this wonderful game that
they just released a few years ago the
anniversary edition and they forgot one
cool feature while we were talking about
that you can switch between the legacy
graphics and the new modern graphics so
cool you can just do that on the fly in
the game that's pretty cool and I
thought that would be also fun for other
games you know while we were talking
about just like enable the kind of
legacy view I love that I know you could
get the roller coaster tycoon 3 look in
planet coaster if you turned the
graphics all the way down to lowest and
then turn the shadows off yeah and then
if you use the Ted jet cam and zoom some
little bit in you can even get a bit of
an isometric so you've got a wonderful
graphics you've got a great game
everything is super cool but then you
just do it just for the legacy that's
that's so 2020
yeah may I by the way ask is this
building in in in the habitat itself so
are the you probably don't know the
chimps will be able to climb so my idea
was to just attach like anti climbing
things to the poles that the buildings
in because yeah it's standing like
inside the grounds of the habitat yeah
so it's also going to take a lot of yeah
yeah it's it's gonna take a lot of
clever rock work also to have Rock work
on the sides but at the same time make
sure that they won't be able to climb
the rock work so it's it's gonna be a
case of trial and error to make this
this whole thing work for sure yeah
you're also gonna have to look into
jumping that's something I could quite a
bit with they leave they but I think
I don't know when frontier added that I
think they first added the jumping for
big cats which destroyed half of my zoos
needed to change no no at that later in
no not in the final game oh I'm sorry
they noticed that a quite a bit later
and then and I think they might have
changed also something to the jumping in
general so that some animals could jump
further than he did before
oh yeah I had a girl really jumping over
a log like the thick log just from one
side of the terrain over it to be honest
and so yeah definitely
guys we have to tell him so that he can
turn off all the alerts everything I
mean that's one of them I actually have
to give props to frontier I think that
was one of the biggest complains of
sandbox players from the very first
minute and they actually deliver it
quite quickly yeah I mean they it took
one more update to do disable the
freaking protesters as well but only
annoying thing is is that if you do that
in sandbox mode and you start franchise
mode it's all the same server like the
same option or like separate options for
franchise and sandbox mm-hmm but honest
and out that left to one of my best ever
episodes and franchise because my my zoo
was kind of going so bad and I didn't
notice I was just doing some
purification works completely chilled
and also he's working super cool super
good and everyone in the comments like
he's not noticing that his whole Jesus
doomed now and the next episode I was
figuring that my animals starved and
everything was littered right you're
playing and you're doing so much your
best to pay attention to everything and
always the people are like oh you didn't
see this you didn't see that I'm like ah
shoe it you know you know different when
people are looking at a video and they
see everything and while you're playing
you're like missing out so many things
yeah yeah actually I was looking for
bamboo pieces in general in the game
which are very rare there's only the
Asian I mean the African sort of bamboo
fence pieces but at the end of the day I
just sort of went for this this wooden
pole and recolored it to the bamboo
rest's color but yeah I think it works
all right just want this whole thing to
look slightly different from all of the
other climbing frames and monkey
habitats in general definitely worked
out so I gotta say I'm really excited
for for what kind of pieces we get in
the future because honestly I was I was
lately thinking about the fact that how
different Planko looked in the first
would say one two areas before the DLC
dropped and then you know after the
first deal sees I think spooky added a
lot of great pieces we we could use for
making some stuff more detailed but I
think planets who already got a good you
know variation of pieces to make it look
as good as Blanco bills you know and
then I'm really curious to see how much
this change is now with a lot more
pieces in the future Riku that yes we
have like a very good solid generic just
items in general like a lot of stuff can
be used for a lot of different themes
and I think qawalli also really proves
that you can just do whatever you want
yeah you can make anything in plans if
you just have the patience for it yeah
oh yeah for sure patience is the key
word mm-hmm I was always wasn't it I
mean yeah you never get something easy
and play that ghost know especially
controversial statement no I mean I mean
I remember the first time I saw the four
meter technique mm-hmm I was like who on
this freaking mother earth would do that
and everybody two days later I tested it
[Laughter]
oh you're making my ugly wall look
better but the ugly walls not staying
[Laughter]
I didn't touch it I added some foliage
around it that's the strategy for making
ugly things look less ugly with small
pears
that girl actually this isn't a small
path I was thinking about it I was
trying to for a while but then I gave up
on that idea that got way too annoying
for a really long time I actually did
try to make a small path here like a two
meter one but due to the fact that it
was both on an incline and elevated and
trying to connect the non elevated
pieces I just couldn't get the
connections to work so it's just four
meters wide in the end sadly maybe it's
not staying that way yeah feel free to
touch my stuff the most work goes in my
stuff yeah yeah yeah I get it I get it I
get it but it's better I see one day we
just have an episode where mike is
removing a spire of fire yeah just to
secure my dominance I'll just remove one
that's how you assert dominance and then
you're just putting it on some of lady's
buildings so here just saw one issue two
issues at the time sections yeah just
let's just unify it at the end of the
day making it look like wall-e beach
again cuz I put that true
nice try but back back to the old stuff
you know first idea oh I like this
little viewing platform here yeah this
is originally I also wanted this to be
functional and to be like a 2 meter path
but I'm very done with that I think you
know I'm still I'm still so much into
into the fact that zookeepers and
especially staff can walk on anything as
long as it's inside and having that and
I'm good to know that the AI and the
kind of bodies I don't know how to call
it into the game can do it I'm fearing
just that the real people don't do it
because of performance reasons yeah I'd
love to see if they do something like
that in the future like having a
wayfinding that is completely using
every scenery object that will be insane
[Music]
like I mean I was can can find their way
so yeah exactly that's right like why
we're having trouble with lag yeah yeah
it's just about to say if that gets
added then my computer is gonna go into
the negative you don't need heating in
winter then plus we don't have winter so
that's I mean that's yeah it's been very
winter this year did you know I'm still
praying for snow gosh
yep
actually we're not really doomed I mean
all this means that in the future we're
gonna be able to grow palm trees and
like have wine
and from from the Netherlands and
Belgium for us it's not so bad and then
vicious fires during the summer talking
of wine by the way it's it's gonna be
the first year in the history of
humankind in Germany at least that you
don't get ice wine
you know what ice - that's the opposite
of gluhwein ya know basically it is it's
kind of a special a special sort of wine
that you there's a special way of doing
it and then it has to be minus seven
degrees especially for one night and
then they kind of bring it down into the
basement and they have a special
technique of moving into whole night so
it's slightly freezing and then you have
like it's more almost like crushed ice
you know but it's actually pretty cool
then it's actually really tasty some
cool but you can only do when you have
one solid night which is minus 7 degrees
and the first year ever
it's not gonna happen
no with the technology with the freezer
no I mean like if you have something
indoors I you know the things I believe
you won't do build that for one year
because it's like a whole big room when
you have to do that like the whole I
mean freezer and so I guess if it is the
same way the next couple of years I can
definitely imagine they do this but not
for now yeah okay
side effect you know that that's it for
this episode so you guys are gonna catch
some pictures later because I have to
close planet Zoo because there's like
[Music]
I'll send some stuff later we feel
gypped makes us watches as well so he's
getting that extra money
know you guys are getting exclusive
screenshots don't worry I look forward
to it to the one FPS I hope that really
after calculating all of the the par
thing it's it's gonna it's gonna work
out just leave it running overnight so
it's gonna be warm in your room you
don't need a blanket then so it's fine
maybe it helps if we open the game for
you then save it again when it
calculates the pot next time lady I
think I'm just gonna come over to your
house I'm just gonna work on the episode
oh yeah but not if you're in Brussels
then it will be too far you can easily
closer to me then well but you're always
welcome to record of my place I don't
worry Oh awesome
I'll consider the option then yeah you
can record in my place but it might be a
little further
we're fitting it we're finished right in
[Laughter]
[Music]
the reports are getting a little crazy
here they don't we just do a little game
we just say the one who's getting the
most views on equality zu it's going to
pay for the ticket so so we're gonna
wrap it up right I'd like to thank you
guys for coming out here and recording
this episode with me yep actually we
should probably keep these episodes a
little bit more sure they've probably
been getting too much on the long side
yeah by Mike Wehmeyer my people the link
to mine nobody's told me like oh my god
too long no fact also it might be me who
started that
yeah but uh it's today has been a good
timing I think and overall still managed
to scramble together at least an episode
but I'm very curious to see where this
area will go in the next few times that
somebody's gonna work on it overall the
park is is a bit messy and it's gonna be
kind of what I'm trying to do next week
I was about to say to ask what are you
gonna do yeah the idea is to like I
potentially won't start anything very
new in that kind of send sense it's it's
gonna be more like filling in some gaps
and right I had some ideas let's see how
it goes and maybe maybe a tiny little
area but not nothing really honestly not
even the scale of the Lemur house and
then just some stuff in between
just like wholesome some stuff I think
so architecture will be really good with
the idea that you have in mind no - yeah
okay mm-hmm
thank you guys all for coming out here
and thank you viewers for watching this
video and we'll see you on Ruby's
Channel next week thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]